[Música]
rusia confirmó el inicio de una nueva
fase centrada en la liberación completa
de las regiones prorrusas de donges y lo
ans al este de ucrania moscú de un
ultimátum de rendición a los militares
ucranianos en mariupol donde se cree que
al menos 1000 civiles están escondidos
en refugio bajo una planta siderúrgica
el fondo monetario internacional- se
mostró pesimista frente a la economía
mundial el organismo redujo su
proyección de crecimiento mundial para
2022 y 2023 y culpó a la guerra en
ucrania
los candidatos a la presidencia de
francia emmanuel macrón y marine lepén
tendrán un debate cara a cara este
miércoles previo a la segunda vuelta del
24 de abril y para muchos franceses el
acceso a la vivienda es una de sus
principales preocupaciones
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 si rodrigo se dan hoy es un
gusto acompañarlos comenzamos este
informativo en ucrania donde transcurre
el día 55 desde que inició la invasión
rusa el ministro de relaciones
exteriores de rusia serguéi lávrov
confirmó este martes que una nueva fase
de la llamada operación militar especial
de moscú ha comenzado sus declaraciones
se dan después de que el presidente
ucraniano volodymyr selenski asegurara
que ya había iniciado la batalla por el
donbass
y la operación en el este de ucrania fue
lanzada tal y como fue anunciado desde
el principio para liberar completamente
a las repúblicas de donges y lugansk y
esta operación continuará otra etapa de
esta operación está comenzando y estoy
seguro de que será un momento muy
importante para toda esta operación
especial en este contexto con rusia
anunciando la nueva fase de su ofensiva
sobre la región del donbass las fuerzas
del kremlin han tomado el control de la
ciudad de cree mina en el este de
ucrania según el gobernador regional
moscú dice que lanzó docenas de ataques
aéreos
del territorio ucraniano durante la
noche después de una intensa noche de
bombardeos en su mí en el noreste de
ucrania los trabajadores de emergencia
limpian lo que queda de las casas el
ministerio de defensa ruso asegura que
sus tropas atacaron 60 sitios militares
ucranianos en la madrugada después de
que moscú iniciará el lunes por la noche
una nueva ofensiva en la región de
bombas
la operación en el este de ucrania fue
lanzada tal y como fue anunciado desde
el principio para liberar completamente
a las repúblicas de donges y lugansk en
la región oriental es mayoritariamente
de habla rusa y los separatistas
respaldados por moscú llevan ocho años
luchando contra las fuerzas ucranianas
el ejército ruso tomó este martes la
ciudad oriental de cree mina el
gobernador regional dijo que las tropas
ucranianas se habían retirado de la
ciudad las fuerzas rusas están atacando
ahora las posiciones ucranianas a lo
largo de los 480 kilómetros de la línea
del frente regis que ocupó a los
ocupantes rusos han intensificado las
operaciones ofensivas a lo largo de toda
la línea de contacto los principales
esfuerzos del enemigo entran en romper
la defensa de las tropas ucranianas en
lugar y daniel woolls esta hospedería de
la región desde un jet los residentes
fueron evacuados antes del nuevo asalto
las autoridades ucranianas instalaron a
los habitantes de donbass a huir hacia
el oeste aunque suspendieron las
evacuaciones por tercer día consecutivo
de las ciudades en primera línea debido
a los continuos combates y en mariupol
se cree que al menos 1000 civiles están
escondidos en refugios subterráneos bajo
una enorme planta siderúrgica las
autoridades de la localidad dijeron que
eran en su mayoría mujeres niños y
ancianos pero también están escondidos
dentro algunos miembros del
ultranacionalista batallón azor mosco
había dado un ultimátum a estos para que
se rindieran y depusieran las armas
antes del mediodía hora local
posteriormente el ministerio de defensa
ruso anunció la apertura de un corredor
humanitario para aquellos militares que
aceptaron deponer las armas
ucrania no ha reconocido ninguna
rendición por el momento el ejército
ruso espera tomar definitivamente la
planta este martes más en el siguiente
informe
negándose a rendirse
la planta de acero a dobbs tal es uno de
los últimos focos de resistencia del
ultranacionalista batallón azor
conocidos en mariupol y ahora es el foco
de los bombardeos rusos en la ciudad
portuaria arrasada mientras moscú
intensifica su ofensiva para tomar el
este de ucrania
junto a lo que queda de la resistencia
de la ciudad también se informa que hay
más de mil civiles refugiándose bajo
tierra
hay cientos de civiles en la fábrica a
shocks tal entre ellos hay muchas
mujeres niños y ancianos los ocupantes
rusos son conscientes de que hay civiles
aquí pero siguen lanzando bombas de
fragmentación cohetes y todos los
proyectiles de artillería posibles
incluso desde buques de guerra como su
estrés corvil prokopenko hizo un
llamamiento a los líderes mundiales para
que impulsen un corredor humanitario que
permita a los civiles huir ya las
familias enterrar a sus muertos con
dignidad funcionarios de kiev dijeron
que aviones de guerra rusos se
preparaban para lanzar bombas de 5
toneladas sobre la planta de azov tal
tras casi dos meses invadiendo ucrania
las tropas de vladimir putin se han
visto obligadas a reagruparse ya han
anunciado el inicio de una nueva fase de
la guerra enfocada en lo que llaman la
liberación del donbass la ciudad clave
de mariupol les permitiría completar un
puente terrestre entre la península de
crimea ocupada y las fuerzas en las
regiones separatistas de donestsk y
lugansk y el fondo monetario
internacional rebajó su proyección de
crecimiento para 2022 y 2023
de la guerra en ucrania durante la
asamblea conjunta anual de primavera de
este organismo y el banco mundial el que
es uno de los mayores prestamistas
mundiales dijo que este año el
crecimiento global podría ser del 3 6% y
no del 4,4 que pronosticaban enero antes
de que comenzara el conflicto para 2023
la perspectiva es del 36 por ciento un
poco menos que el 38 por ciento previsto
hace tres meses el organismo destaca que
la guerra se produjo justo cuando la
economía mundial comenzaba a sacudirse
de los efectos de la pandemia lo que ya
se notaba con el crecimiento del
producto interior bruto mundial del 61
el año pasado
en comparación con nuestro pronóstico de
enero hemos revisado a la baja nuestra
proyección de crecimiento global al 3.6
por ciento tanto en 2022 como en 2023
esto refleja el impacto directo de la
guerra en ucrania y las sanciones contra
rusia en ambos países se prevé que se
experimenten fuertes contracciones
actions y nos vamos hasta afganistán
donde al menos seis personas murieron y
numerosas resultaron heridas después del
ataque con explosivos en centros
educativos de la minoría chiquita
azahara en el oeste de kabul las
autoridades no descartan que aumente el
número de fallecidos debido al estado de
gravedad en algunos heridos los
atentados aún no han sido reivindicados
por ningún grupo extremista pero la
comunidad hazara suele ser tomada por
objetivos de los ataques de grupos
extremistas sunitas incluyendo el estado
islámico el ataque fue justo a la hora
de la salida de clase con una cadena de
explosiones
y acabamos en francia antes de la
segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales del domingo 24 de abril
los candidatos al elíseo de manuel
macrón y marie le pen tendrán un debate
cara a cara en la televisión francesa
una de las demandas de los franceses
para nuevo presidente es el derecho a la
vivienda desde 2012 se ha doblado el
número de personas sin hogar y muchos
piden soluciones al estado gabriel coll
sanz tiene los detalles
otro desafío del nuevo quinquenio en
francia el respeto del derecho a la
vivienda es lo que pidieron los
manifestantes que se reunieron frente a
las sedes de los partidos de los dos
candidatos finalistas
hablan del poder adquisitivo del poder
adquisitivo pero hoy para gran parte de
los franceses es el 50 o 60 por ciento
de los ingresos que se destina a la
vivienda son personas que trabajan
personas que recogen nuestra basura
personas que cuidan nuestros mayores
personas que trabajan en hospitales que
hacen la limpieza que reponen las
estanterías personas cuyos hijos están
en el colegio de mis hijos no puedo
mirar les y decirle bueno no es tan malo
de dormir en tu coche o dormir el social
el social no nos culpa no en teoría la
ley de alud de 2007 es reconoce un
derecho a la vivienda para cualquier
residente de francia que no puede
acceder a ella por sus propios medios
pero el país cuenta con al menos 300.000
personas sin hogar
os pedimos que se respeten las leyes y
los derechos que protegen a las personas
sin hogar el derecho al alojamiento
hasta el realojamiento pedimos el
respeto de los derechos y la aplicación
de las leyes
decenas de inmigrantes sin documentos
ocuparon locales desocupados en el
distrito 9 de parís para exigir el
cumplimiento de este derecho no nos
apetece decir la prueba está en ucrania
es decir es posible establecer todo un
sistema de alojamiento dar papeles a
todos dar transporte gratuito a todos
son cosas por la que llevamos luchando
40 años 50 años y francia lo ha hecho en
15 días en sus pancartas se podía leer
no al racismo o las vidas de los
migrantes importan y quiero invitar a
todos los espectadores a que mañana
miércoles sintonicen france24 alaska
horas de bogotá quito y lima para
nuestro especial sobre el debate
presidencial en francia hasta aquí este
informativo sigan con nosotros
[Música]